[Musique]
euh
d'accord,
regardez attentivement s'il vous plaît et
croyez-moi, j'ai filtré ces choses tellement
de fois que je peux presque le faire les
yeux fermés
en fait, je vais d'abord
aiguiser votre couteau,
construire la branchie
et littéralement
trancher  à travers là
tirez en arrière traversez retournez le poisson
trouvez que l'os central
laissez le couteau faire le travail
descendez jusqu'au bout et
traversez
la cage thoracique avec
précaution
sans l'éclater une fois que vous avez
traversé la cage thoracique  tu devrais sentir le
saumon s'en aller
sais
parfois il n'y a rien c'est drôle
je ne sais pas dis moi
quoi que ce soit
d'étranger